é so pedro saavedra é sou artista editor
do gerador é e gostava de declarar do
meu amor 5 sai com uma rima que é uma
coisa que geralmente nós temos tendência
ou estar muito ou estar pouco eu quero
falar de amor que é uma palavra quem em
muitas línguas em muitas culturas e
muitos povos do mundo é usada de uma
forma extremamente tranquila
amo essa sobremesa poderia dizer no
brasil
ayoví não sei o quê e em portugal a
palavra amor é uma palavra press ganhou
um peso difícil aceitar que o momento na
relação entre duas pessoas em que se
decida utilizar a palavra amor
mas esta forma de os portugueses têm de
ver a palavra amor é uma forma muito
muito diversa
agora vou fazer o gol no final e porque
estava a tentar descobrir uma forma de
nos declarar o meu amor a vocês que
estão aqui mas tentar fazê-lo de uma
forma verdadeiramente portuguesa ea
síria
eu sou de lisboa toda a vida de vilas
goyer dólares é e nós em lisboa são
tributários
gostamos de dizer este tipo de coisas
vocês são os meus mais que tudo
as pessoas não esgote uma certa
tendência a achar que a conhecem muito
bem o resto país que acham que o país é
geralmente por exemplo norte basta
imitar mas o pinto da costa e estamos a
fazer os destaques é certo e temos esta
ideia de querermos grupos e cremos
gostar das pessoas portanto aqui em
lisboa eu acho que seria algo assim mas
a seguir vamos pensar em caxinas não se
está aqui julgando que a china vai
tentar descobrir alguma expressão que
fosse típica e de uma tática de santa
maria da feira
não descobri então foi revestida de
pastilhas ao caos extraordinário por ter
uma história muito em santa ligado à
povoado por simples em caxias as pessoas
falam das pessoas da póvoa de varzim
como os polacos vocês sabiam e só tem
importados têm uma forma muito
interessante poder fazer uma declaração
de amor é tia de saibro e sim olhar
mesmo vale para o irb e qualquer coisa
gastronômica qualquer coisa em que
crimes de guerra
sua e fazer qualquer coisa mas noutros
sítios
por exemplo em rápido país é já deve ter
ouvido falar é uma pequena aldeia
piscatória que existe na ilha de são
miguel muito conhecida pelos réus é e
até teve 111 ré porque era o sandro
jorge não se lembra é não chorar é ter
esse tipo de coisa e tamanho mauá e
piscatória que tenho como mirado que é
muito orgulhosa da sua tradição como é
que diria em rabo de peixe
a tam quem é esse uma bela femina
naturalmente que estamos a falar de amor
heterossexual ou dependendo das
perspectivas mas é também uma forma
muito positiva de querer alguém em outro
local um crime mancha distante
vamos agora criar ray miranda do douro
em miranda do douro queda sempre me
apegava e poético aqui qualquer coisa
que é laico portuguesa eu se calhar não
gostariam que eu dissesse assim ressalva
forma sensitiva apaixonava de falar em
assumir andrés tem muitas pressões que
nos fazem lembrar aquelas cantigas de
amigo que nos fazem lembrar um tempo
onde repente dizer é muito era uma coisa
extremamente complexa e que ser feita
com uma métrica muito específica é
seguirem para o boleto para pensar onde
a quebra mulher morreu ontem no concelho
de lagos que também é uma terra gira
entre as pessoas do lago diferencial
aqui como ele é e tem coisas
extraordinárias equipa com do ipa não se
ouviu falar sobre o segmento com quilhas
orlandinho dependendo da zona do país é
que os vistos um tipo qualquer das
invasões francesas que era um condômino
ipp ficou a quando empenhar muito como é
que iria me moço lá gosto mais típico de
uma carreira de figueiras aqui qualquer
coisa fantástica porque as figueiras não
se conhecem algarvias para além da
salfer bandeiras e às vezes também houve
várias é uma coisa muito importante as
pessoas definem um patrimônio no algarve
com a quantidade figueiras que tem que
estar mais de alguém do que no reino
mirado de ficar é uma coisa
extraordinária é que a gente sai de
vermos essa diferença entre exemplo
litoral nesta
de precatórias e depois o interior
capital fala de coisas ganharam um pouco
mais problemáticas
a seguir não é nova de são bento é um
sítio muito interessante onde o canto e
não canto alentejano é muito importante
é um sítio perto games mostraste
amanhece na raia como é miranda do douro
mas aí iríamos goste é uma forma
causa além de já no rio pra casa difícil
extraordinário todos nós todos os povos
têm uma zona do país que geralmente
fazem rotas e geralmente são zonas do
país discussões onde as pessoas por
algum tipo são mais lentas tem com a
frança inglaterra e expande é igual mas
de facto os além disso tem uma coisa que
eu admiro muito e eu simpatizo muito bem
emoções idéias
a seguir na furada se você já teve quem
não foi nunca furava ouviu é um
chiqueirinho do e veloso é não saber
como é que mas na frase esta expressão
eu gosto muito que é o filha fazia um
pijaminha de custo
sim podemos pensar que os googlers
também fazem parte da cultura portuguesa
também é uma forma de amar é seguir na
amadora e toda a vida vivi na amadora
num sítio que ficava resolvida observa
josé cruzar com isso que brandle a ser o
maior bairro o destino do da europa
senão do mundo a sair e como é que iria
na amadora e isto essa minha eterna
não deixa de ser verdade sempre falando
de cultura portuguesa nós imaginamos uma
forma estática do que é que a cultura de
um país e neste caso a cultura
portuguesa
estamos a falar de pessoas por
coincidência tem origem africana que
vivem na amadora e que fazem cultura
portuguesa
os buraka som sistema por exemplo é um
exemplo a gente adora e realmente não as
podia utilizar não tem uma ascendência
africana tretas também time e em casa
como é que eu poderia dizer isto à minha
mulher que sou casado como podem ver
aqui faz favor
o amor pode trazer um copo de água
esta ideia de que o amor pode ser
declarado muitas formas é extraordinária
porque em cada um destes sítios é sempre
uma declaração de amor 100 mais sexy
ao ser mais gastronômica não deixa de
ser uma coleção de moda mas agora se não
fosse eu estar aqui declarados o meu
amor e se eu fosse faz favor
outros se não fosse eu vamos começar por
um fácil o dom dinis que é vulgarmente
conhecido como a pessoa que se não o
primeiro decreto escrita em português é
como explicou hoje está prevista uma
nota de vida não se sabe mas é
interessante ter alguém que devia
dinheiro a alguém o que cuidam de
energia em toda a gente a lei está em
florença foi divertido se saber de novas
do meu amigo ai deus e o henry esta
ideia lírica que estávamos a sentir
também no grandeza esta ligação
fantástica ea idéia de amigo é moroso
não é como em frente a um crime mais à
frente cerca de 300 anos depois o camões
esta toda a gente sabe o amor é fogo que
arde sem se ver é ferida que dói
inocente é um contentamento descontente
e dor que desatina sendo investida é
lírica sofrimento de nós desejamos ao
ganhou alguma coisa é muito
evidentemente é uma coisa muito
portuguesa é curioso nesta altura e como
sabe o camões e não sustentam muito
interligados no momento histórico a
crônicas dos tipos holandeses na altura
ainda países baixos que vieram a lisboa
que é o sítio que era a capital do mpl
fizeram crônica sempre falavam que os
lisboetas e os portugueses em geral é
muito arrogante e se achavam donos do
mundo e é curioso como essa parte não
ficou tão enraizado na nossa cultura mas
esta parte sofrimento esta parte de
querermos atingir um resultado e não
interessa se atingimos importante sofrer
para lá chegar
isso ficou muito é seguir um caminho
mais à frente teria decolado fran pessoa
o século 20 tem essa vantagem neste
momento os modernismos e do futurismo
sente o fernandinho aconteceu a favor
parece uma coisa que é o individualismo
nunca mais ninguém
andamos tão somente a idéia que fazemos
de alguém é um conceito nosso em suma é
nós mesmos que - e parece extremamente
individualista parece que o século 21
começa de uma forma muito de frente que
o lirismo do caminho
não deixa de ter dor é dor não está
agora como casa no outro a gol está
colocada em nós próprios portanto pessoa
e o camões não estão assim tão diferente
atuando é que os quase 500 anos que os
passos a seguir
o lanche eu gosto muito desse senhor
porque se ele tem um estatuto militar é
mole não sei se o avião era um poeta
popular como existem tanto de você
provavelmente conhece e já encontraram
alguém que numa taberna uma tática que
nunca fé
de repente diz poemas e como é que era o
amor provar isso o amor para o lanche o
amor pra lá e fazermos aquele momento
motorolas brigar bruno que fui assistir
o meu desde a hora em que teve jogo até
que estou no céu quando estou pt
isto é muito simples presse uma forma
fácil de dizer mas é muito sensível e
uma das coisas que em portugal eu por
exemplo agora vou inventar um estudo que
é peixe por ser estatisticamente provar
tudo lembrando que eu vi a cara jamais a
flor mel épo - um em cada cinco
portugueses ou editou um livro de poesia
está a pensar fazer o que é uma coisa
muito comum as pessoas fizeram aquelas
universidades sério das primeiras coisas
que acontecem são poemas as pessoas
escrevem com ele a qualquer coisa não
acidente dado que nos faz ter essa
vontade poética e agora florbela essa
pessoa extraordinária mulher a primeira
mulher que eu sinto aqui portanto dizer
como diria a favela mas quem se amanhã e
não quem se quer amar quem essa flor
bela aquela música que a maioria tenha
se levanta marta é para que esse
empreendimento é falou ela tenha uma
forma de amar muito forte mas temos que
lembrar que na altura em que foi escrito
uma mulher está é discernir sobre o que
é o amor e que maneira que vemos de mar
era uma coisa extraordinária por algum
motivo ela teve uma vida horrível não
sei se o filme que o vicentão sul fez em
primeiro e ele está muito bem retratado
essa dor
a seguir temos de ser magro é o nosso
prémio nobel é sua fantástica que diria
como sou o amor nos
conhecermo-nos o saramago por acaso eu
mesmo assim do que eu tenho uma coisa
que a china está sempre a falar de si
próprio não sei se repararam mas pelo
menos em minha opinião há uma idéia de
autoconhecimento a uma idéia de nós
temos o poder de alterar o mundo e isso
é uma diferença muito grande que
estávamos a ver do camões da que eu
estava vendo pessoa e até da flor bela
a seguir temos apostila e tenho de falar
agostina
como é que a justiça diria o amor é o
invisível no habitual
a china é muito turística é uma pessoa
realmente teve uma vida além daquela
argel em que ela tem que ter uma forma
que eu diria muito northern a sentir as
emoções nos 60 isso sim que esta ideia
de que o amor é invisível mas existe a
nossa volta é uma coisa muito muito
forte nem na china
a seguir bom vamos amar indexante não
tenham mesmo assim eu vou falar a favor
do festival rtp da canção minha palavra
de que a luz do sol nascente madrigal de
madrugada vocês vão ver um estranho amor
amor amor amor amor presente é cada
espiga deles folhada espera uma forma de
dizer uma série de coisas pois na altura
não se podiam dizer uma série de coisas
e se prepararem e suélen letra todas do
marinho poema completo é ter um poema
com uma carga erótica bastante grande
mas a seguir temos o antónio variações
que também marca imenso é cultura
portuguesa que diria o que não eu vou
cantar e eu nem levo que fumei é o tempo
que faz bem amor é um porque eu não sei
o que é um momento em que doem e já
estamos nesta fase pós 25 de abril
outras tantas coisas começam a ser mais
fáceis dizer que a seguir temos a ágata
é verdade não se sustenta é cultura
portuguesa da mesma maneira que na
amadora é uma cultura mais africana
continua a ser cultura portuguesa e
promove e desenvolve
contra a portuguesa é música pimba e
deixou o pingo em páginas a toda a gente
sabe do que estou a falar
é fundamental como é que a declaração de
amor mais dita maldita amor que meu quem
se às vezes parece que fazes bruxedos e
já ouviram isto pois é tão grande o
sentimento que sinto esta ideia é ele
mantém uma maneira geral de falar das
letras do tony carreira também 37 pra
que que é eu sabia que o ronaldo e agora
porque o ronaldo e agora vê este choque
tanto ronaldo como morini são do mais
contemporâneo que existe na cultura
portuguesa e porque é eu não sou
historiador mas há 800 anos de história
português que se assume perante outros
no mundo com os melhores fãs provou
frases sou o primeiro segundo e terceiro
melhor jogador do mundo e tem uma
arrogância não tipicamente portuguesa
o inglês poderia dizer isso ou não 3
dizeres zoom portuguesa dizer isto é uma
coisa extraordinária e de que maneira é
que existe essa influência é uma coisa
que não sabemos mas o seguinte vamos
então fazer amor com o gênero favor
a primeira vez foi assim mas trai a
fotografia ao que parece uma banda riam
se quiserem uma banda de rock eu sou teu
tamanho ligeiramente inclinado temos o
thiago está com uma gravata temporada
que é o cérebro do jogador
eu amei pessoal mandou geradora e outros
e inclinada a miguel bica que o coração
dos jogadores foi a maneira que nós
tivemos disse lippi não temos aquelas
coisas do director e directora a
estratégia como é que isto começou hoje
um projeto que começou sobretudo para um
evento chamado pt
não sei se vocês já ouviram falar de um
projecto que esteve bastante polêmico em
lisboa em que uma marca terá implicações
na altura com o engenheiro civil comprar
o neném de uma estação de metro que
chamada baixíssima do pt bluestation
nessa estação do metro aconteceu nessas
coisas mas diversos profissionais para
essa marca eo miguel bica está
wii é fazer o contrário é era o produtor
eu era o director de tiago era o patrão
o thiago era a pessoa que vier a
apresentar à pt nisto não juntarmos e
lançamos aqui uma espécie de um desafio
que surgiu o primeiro do thiago que pode
mais usar um político que era como fazer
cultura portuguesa para todos fazendo
isso pago por dinheiro privado pediu
silêncio
como é que nós conversemos marcas é
privado em expira em em cultura e
dinamização da cultura e eventos de
cultura informa
e foi essa pergunta que no jogo ao
gerador e ativa identificar e raízes ea
idéia de que quando falta eletricidade
liga sul gerador e começar nos colocou a
primeira comunhão ok parece uma coisa
saída religiosa é mas de facto que foi a
primeira comunhão
nós começámos por criar uma rede de
parceiros aquilo é cruel
precisamos proteger a rede de parceiros
de todo o país e pôr o caso para dizer
como com amor é o porto foi decidido nos
acolheram melhores voltarmos lá com
vinte e tal passagem e primeira reunião
foi um evento que fizemos em julho de
2014 ou tentar juntar todos esses
parceiros que vocês podem ver aqui só um
filme e outro juntarmos as pessoas todas
aqui há vários artistas tatá mara está
na costa estava em uma cena dos basquete
e próximo foto porque é importante ver
as pessoas tentavam juntar pessoas do
maio que conversassem sobre o que era
fazer cultura para todos os sem ter medo
de ideologias sem ter medo de coisas que
já aconteceram no passado mas realmente
falaram sobre isto
será que os artistas estão a procurar
chegar ao público
será que o público tem a vontade de
conhecer melhor os artistas e esta foi a
primeira união que nos permitiu passar o
paciente faz favor
foi começarmos a fazer coisas em época
foi transformarmos num órgão de
comunicação e cultura portuguesa tem
muita dificuldade em ser comunicada em
órgãos que são jornais para quem deixar
a legenda
tem muita vontade de fazer portásio
online controla muito isso então nós
erramos em um look e fazer uma revista
favor
esse é o primeiro número basicamente é
uma declaração de amor à cultura
portuguesa trimes vários artistas vários
autores
o nós para nós um autor o goleiro é o o
o artista plástico com o cantor lírico
são autor sobre os que criam e promovem
eventos tirado que é algo que nós
queremos todos juntos e mais heterogéneo
psiu e foi número 1
assim que tivermos um número 2 em
brincar sobre esta coisa dos dois em
quiser usar com esta coisa nós próprios
como eu tomo banho número 1 e tivemos um
feedback é tão bom que tivemos nestas
cidades que tiveram o número 3 em que
brincavam sobre o modernismo e por
coincidência em 2015 aos sonhados da
revista orpheu que foi uma tentativa de
fazer uma revista similar em portugal e
que só conseguiu fazer dois números nós
vamos ele tá pra cima não sei se
portanto alguma coisa está regular ou
pelo menos 36 horas a seguir
tivemos 15 foi feita por um designer do
porto esta revista é sempre feita por um
designer de frente e é sempre com um
tema de frente por acaso foi feita sobre
os subúrbios de e piada da ida e volta
ao centro a seguir tivemos a revista 55
agora no brasil que obviamente quiser
brincar com esse dvd é minha aldeia é
maior do que tudo e falarmos de uma
série de aldeias e concessões à volta
disso é seguir na rua tivemos o
trampolim gerador já aconteceu duas
vezes o último esta que foi na praça das
flores a última das quais foi no é que
não descobrir que foi na praça das
flores ao tecido lacson pau e assim é
foi o príncipe ao que aconteceu
exatamente há duas semanas atrás
mais à frente o que fica e como é que eu
concluiu isto nós queremos fazer coisas
vontade chegarmos a um povo que é o que
de certa maneira sem necessidade de
construir a autoestima deles passados
menos chato é que nos tem dito umas
coisas muito chatas é que estão sempre a
dizer que as nossas opções parecem não
são as mais corretas
chico está aconteceu tudo na nossa
história muitas vezes e não é visto mais
do que o território mais do que economia
mais do que o orçamento do estado
existem as identidade existe aquilo que
nos faz ser condições não contra os
outros mas que nos faz ser realmente com
os homens as coisinhas que os
portugueses realmente sentem quando vão
viajar lá fora e quando voltam e 60
vontade de comer um prato bacalhau à
brás e no momento em que fazemos um
prato bacalhau à brás que estamos a ser
autores e criadores de cultura
portuguesa
muito obrigado